and we're pleased to have here to talk a
little bit of baseball our baseball hall
of fame friend from mlb and also from
fox
is john smoltz how are you john i'm
doing good man thanks hope you are too i
am my help my family's uh healthy uh
we're going a little bit crazy but uh
you know we're knocking on wood on that
front i hope the same for you
yes absolutely excellent all right john
um
in your days in major league baseball
from 1988 all the way through to uh
2009 you saw quite a quite some
conversations between baseball and the
union what were you thinking as you were
watching
uh all of these machinations over the
last few weeks trying to put a 2020
season together
well much like when i went through it
personally as a player you realize
that not everything that everybody hears
in the media or in the
you know in the papers is accurately
going to be described sometimes it works
as posturing sometimes it's a scenario
where it's not even close but i thought
the whole time that something would be
worked out i remained optimistic
just having been through it knowing that
it's not always depicted the right way
so
uh look it it's always a
tenuous situation when you're trying to
negotiate something under normal
circumstances
i can't even imagine what it's like to
throw in a million other uh
up possibilities in trying to figure
that out so it was definitely on the
outside looking in people don't really
understand
how this came to be but the good news is
it's uh
it's where it is right now and baseball
is going to be played and it's going to
be
one of the most intriguing and exciting
seasons we've ever seen although be at
60 games
that's the big part of what makes it so
intriguing
exactly um and i i do want to get into
that baseball discussion and go down
that wormhole and talk about the game
um and what the season might look like
from from a strategy standpoint and
obviously a wins and losses standpoint
but i do want to just linger a little
bit here on
what you just said about not everything
gets reported properly
um what what did you mean by by that
john well i think that you you send your
message out to
at times and and depending on how it's
received or depending on how it's even
you know written sometimes gets little
pockets of information
get out whether you know that's the
majority or the minority of feeling
something in a in a situation where you
have
a negotiation going on so you know i i
just know that back when we
were doing what we were doing it was a
total different set of circumstances it
was a
more veteran-laden kind of experienced
leadership in the baseball was more
filled with
older players this is a totally
different set of
players and a totally different set of
circumstances so i don't think the two
climate
quite come together as the same and
leadership's different so you know
all that being said you're going to have
things and you just hope you hope
players are as informed as they can be
and and
certainly uh represent the voices as
best as they can
yeah i know but i i guess the mistrust
between both sides still lingers uh john
i mean
that that yeah there's no doubt there's
there's definitely going to be some
bumpy roads down the road i mean
they still have to work out some kinks
just like um
again you know the last three to four
years uh
you're going to have two sets of
narrative players are going to believe
something the owners are going to
believe something that's why you have an
impasse at times and you try to figure
out how to come
to an understanding and you hope as we
were
hoping that leadership represents the
mass of
opinion rather than a small pocket you
know that
not being in that anymore i have no way
of knowing you know how how that played
out but
but but i go back to you know having
this
it's hard to carve out a timeout like
this should have been a time out in our
world
because this is unprecedented
circumstances
so disagreements should definitely be on
hold but the timeout should have figured
out a way to get baseball played and
however it got to i'm glad we're playing
baseball
exactly and um you know everyone's
supposed to report um
by i guess next wednesday uh in just a
matter of days
john smoltz here on the rich eisen show
biggest challenge is what
for getting ready here but honestly the
biggest challenge
is going to seem weird the biggest
challenge is the mental uh
change that every player is going to
have to have and i'm talking about
playing in front of an empty stadium to
having four months off to not being in
game
scenarios that you would be totally your
body's ready for this type of the year
to make that push
it's going to be fresh it's going to
help a lot of people who've been hurting
and have injuries that's
definitely going to be one side effect
that's good but i think players
are going to have to be creative and
they're thinking of how do they stay
maintained focused without the
the extra adrenaline with fans and the
extra narrative that
they're normally used to right travel is
going to be somewhat the same although
regional
it's just going to be odd for a while
and the players especially that are
going to have the most
to try to get ready in their own
work is the pitchers because the
pitchers are going to miss
out on a lot of reps that get them ready
for the up and downs and get them ready
for the long haul of the season now it's
a sprint
so pitchers the first two weeks are
going to have to figure out how quickly
they're connected to their mechanics
the pitchers with the least awkward
mechanics in other words the ones that
are most tied to their mechanics that
have a smooth delivery are going to be
the ones that jump out
my opinion in front and have an
advantage
the high working high velocity much
needed to get in tune with their
mechanics may struggle early on and
let's face it the pressure's on because
you don't have a lot of time to struggle
in theory because you know it's only 60
games
so give me some names of some of those
pictures that you're talking about
john well you know i mean the veteran
pitchers should have a nod anyways
because they've been through
so much of of of what they know
they can pitch right but i i think
offhand you know like
guys who don't throw super hard but
command the strike saw i think strike
throwers are going to have a real
decided advantage
uh in the early end uh the guys with
stuff you know yeah the hitters still
have face hitter
face pitching live pitching that's
that's all true but i think of of of in
this
this world like maybe a kyle hendricks
you know he's the name that just jumps
out to me he can throw strikes he could
probably
take four months off and always throw
strikes i'm guessing
so that guy's going to have some value
right away for the cubs but i think
anybody
who doesn't rely strictly on high
velocity to be effective
that can find the the strike zone is
going to have and going to be
you know i mean shoot guys like clayton
kershaw and bumgarner insurers are in
herlander and
i don't think those guys are going to
necessarily have
issues it's just i know from past
experiences
as hard throwers get into rhythm it
takes them a little while into the
season to be connected to where it now
clicks
and that's where the dominance comes in
when it clicks those guys
are what the reason why they're the best
john smoltz here
on the rich eisen show you mentioned um
how
difficult it's going to be or at least
for an adjustment to
play in front of no fans what are we
going to hear
what are we as fans going to hear that
we uh we normally wouldn't
john well let me take you back to 1988
and 89 in the atlanta braves stadium
when there was 1500 fans
hear the lights buzzing you're gonna
hear people you can hear everything here
the ball hit the seats
so i found myself wandering too many
times on the mount hearing things you
normally don't hear
and that's the discipline of
concentration that i'm talking about i
mean
you're going to hear the dugouts yelling
you're going to hear everything that you
would never hear because the dull roar
that is actually in a stadium
and you're going to hear the you know
cracks in
of the bat and all the things so that
part getting spring training
in their in their cities in their parks
without any fans is gonna help
but it's still weird man it goes back to
you know american legion days maybe even
little league well little league you
still have parents that are
yelling that he's one of their children
but get them all down
keep your eye on it right uh so i i
think
the creative teams are really going to
get out front both philosophically
changing some philosophical uh
strategies
and maybe having fun in the dugout with
with some bad banter and chatter that
you would only hear
kind of in little league and american
league legion so
that part is going to be intriguing and
and to be honest it's going to be very
uh
challenging for the broadcasters as well
because it's going to be different
except for the ones that are there on
site it's going to be a whole challenge
for every industry to figure out how you
can adapt to something that's new
something that has a little excitement
behind it but also a little trepidation
of the fact that you don't
know this this is foreign to everybody
and
i i really look forward to see the teams
that are cohesive
and get out front and collectively work
a plan
out are going to be the team that has
success i really believe that
all right so you left a couple strands i
want to pull on here john first things
first in terms of the broadcasting if
you and fox and mlb network had
conversations about what this looks like
are you going to be sitting
in your home uh for some of these
calling the games has that already been
a conversation for you
john yeah that's been part of the
conversation i know both entities are
looking at the best way to keep
everybody in a healthy and safe way and
free and bring a broadcast to the
people's homes
in the best form that they can you've
seen other sports doing this
this kind of stuff i think you're going
to see similar scenarios play out that's
what's
that's what's got me a little nervous of
the unknown i like structure i want to
desperately get back to structure
um you know i've never uh played this
much golf in my life so i'm not
complaining about the golf part
right but i do like structure and then
having to squeeze in golf
makes me feel like i'm back where i need
to be okay uh instead of every day
you know uh being uh groundhog day would
you be would you be cool or do you think
the players would be fine if
if uh to get some sort of home field
advantage um
certainly when the playoffs roll around
to get some sort of crowd noise where
it's difficult for the pitcher to think
difficult uh for the hitter to uh focus
that sort of thing would you be fine
with that
being pumped in you mean pumping in
crowds yes sir to make it
to make it some sort of home field
advantage you know what
you know what it's like when the towels
are waving and you're on the road
did the falcons get in trouble for that
oh i should cry no no
also yeah no the reason why i'm bringing
this up is i'm talking about that for
the nfl too like yeah that there there's
and when the nba returns the nhl returns
to try and create
something to uh enhance or or get it as
close to as possible what it would be
like
normally you know yeah i doubt wherever
i doubt we're going to see that there's
just too many uh
scenarios that could be created there
unfairly other than the natural
uh crowd that is understanding the
moment so
again i i'm hopeful you know i'm hopeful
we'll trend in the right direction and
we'll be able to get
crowds at the end of the year don't know
if that's going to be the case or not
but
but this is a step in the right
direction from the fact that baseball is
going to be played it's going to be
viewed
there's going to be an excitement that
i've you know you and i've talked about
my first half second half scenario
they'll need to go back into it but
here's a preview of it
you're going to get a small preview of
what that's like to know that let's say
this is the second half of the season
and it's a sprint to the playoffs for
that particular team that would not have
had a chance in a 162. i think there's a
lot of things that could come out of
this season
um you know things that they like or
don't like about potential rule changes
that could be
really why not this is the perfect
scenario to throw out whatever you think
is goofy great or bad
and and test it out because no one's
going to have an advantage
in any of these rule changes that have
taken place and i i just
i can't wait to watch this sprint
because i know
after 21 years of playing 162 games and
14 straight years of going to the
postseason what a grind
and what a roster and how important it
is to have a roster
um set up for 162. now you're bringing
in at least 30 percent of the teams
that would not have had a chance had we
started this season on time and played
out this to its fulfillment so i
that part i cannot wait as a broadcaster
to look out
and see the teams that are impacted
differently by this schedule okay so
then
i was going to ask you about the second
thing the second strand that you wanted
me to pull on i'm gonna i'm gonna hold
off on that
which teams do you think normally over
the 162 would have an issue but over the
60
have got a real shot to make a run here
that we're not talking about okay so
yeah so an example maybe not
looking into it with the roster eye of
knowing how many people are going to be
healthy right
right and how many people are going to
avoid this i would say a good example
would be like a san diego padre where
most people aren't talking about the san
diego padres in 162 but they're talking
about what's coming right they're
talking about the youth
the pitching do they have enough now for
60 games that young pitching has enough
so they could be an upstart and surprise
team that would not be talked about in
162 with all the talent they have
and the cincinnati reds a team that jump
out when you think about all the moves
they made in the off season
and there are opportunities now with a
dh to accompany the
the equi acquisitions they made and
maybe a couple people are out of
position
so the dh is a big thing for a lot of
teams that didn't think that was going
to be in play but maybe anticipated it
by acquiring certain players because you
kind of look and go why did they acquire
that guy
he's out of position and now it looks
pretty good that they got him uh
whether it's a nick castiano's or
who have you so i look at teams that
were a little short pitching but have
talent pitching that over 162 you can't
hide those warts
i liken it to this you play a golf
tournament and one day you can hide your
weakness
try to hide your weakness in four day
tournament it's almost impossible
it comes up and it shows up and that's
what a 162 does for a lot of teams
who don't have the depth and the roster
or the the minor leagues to sustain you
know
the unforeseen of injuries or the likes
of that
and you said earlier that the team that
gets creative uh
mike to have an advantage you weren't
referring to any trash cans were you
john
when you said creative no no no none of
that i was remembering
a strategy on the field that would not
typically be part of our dna today
and i mean getting runners over it's
going to be more important getting that
run in
i think some teams are not going to
deviate they're just going to go ahead
and still try to smash the ball and
power its way
but i think the teams that do deviate in
60 games would have a decided advantage
for creating an opportunity to increase
their chances because in 162 it may not
mean as much
i may i may i may agree with with some
of the analytics that come out there
but i i would argue that in 60 games
you're gonna see
that it might okay a couple more minutes
left with john smoltz baseball hall of
famer in terms of the
uh health and safety protocols that have
been mentioned um
and they are very very stringent
including no spitting
which player or coach from your days as
a player would have had the most
trouble with the no spitting rule john
oh my gosh uh there'd be a lot uh
there's uh
you know the tobacco chewing days um you
know even our skipper bobby cox
would have a shirt kind of dripping with
some of the uh the remnants of the
tobacco as he was trying to get
the umpire's attention on several
different um
what he thought was miss calls so i i
think that's going to be a big time
adjustment too i mean no no
you know this is this is this is what
we're asking everybody to do is try to
for the time being adjust what's normal
and even if you don't agree in theory
and even if you don't agree with certain
people
that are trying to protect everybody
else you're going to have to adhere and
make the best
case scenario out of it you know whether
it's seeds or tobacco or
we don't get much yelling at umpires
anymore well
but uh we'll hear it now we're gonna
hear it i mean all that stuff with the
lip reading on twitter
uh we'll just hear it ourselves now we
don't need any lip reading
uh translation i imagine you know could
you imagine bobby cox that we get to
hear we
we got to hear every word that came out
of his mouth there would have to be an
nc-17 on
on on rating on the games right there
would there would and there would be a
lot of
i i miss a lot of those funny lines he
used to say
and you know one of my favorites uh
bobby cox
uh top of the first uh two outs in the
first and uh
inevitably it would be yelling both ways
um both ways
that's fantastic oh john that's amazing
i love that story that is that is
amazing um
before i let you go how is your golf
game are you ready for well it is
it is good yeah i mean i'm in a club
championship i can't i haven't been able
to play in my club championship because
it's normally in october
okay for the last 12 years that's been
out of the picture so they moved it
to today and tomorrow and uh i gotta
take out a bunch of guys that are half
my age but i'm
this is a great test yeah
for me to get ready for tahoe which is
in a couple weeks yeah
and uh you know i don't have many
things that get my competitive juices
going but uh
these this is this is one of them so uh
for tahoe the american century that is
part of nbc sports
um should romo see smoltz
getting larger in his rear view mirror
or what what what should we say about
that
i mean this is the first time for all of
us uh
you know of course we're not going to
have fans there so the whole idea of
playing
is going to make it easier for some of
the guys who got nervous for for
obvious reasons ten thousand people
standing on a hole but i think for all
of us who have been in the same boat we
it should be one of the best
uh golf playing tournaments in tahoe's
history i would think
you know just based on the availability
to get out there and work on your game
dan if there are no fans i i guess sean
payton won't have a boat to hit off of a
deck you know
sean payton can't hit off anybody's deck
this time you won't have that as a
backstop
on that uh par three it's going to be
odd but i'm glad that they're doing it
and all the proceeds are going to go to
charities
and local charities and you know nbc is
is
is certainly a big part of this
tournament of course putting it on tv
so hopefully it's an exciting and
another opportunity for people to watch
something
who uh haven't had much sports you know
until recently what'd you think of brady
in uh peyton's game
uh with with tiger and and phil i mean
on national television what'd you think
of that one yeah
but that's the thing most people don't
understand is sitting at their couch
they're probably
questioning brady's handicap i can
promise you until you've done something
like that until you know it's being
broadcast
it's way different than hitting casual
golf balls so
i completely understand where he and
some of the guys who have never done
that could get a little nervous but then
i saw him settle down there a little bit
in the back
back nine and uh it's not that easy i
try tell people all the time
but being an armchair quarterback is
much easier and sitting at home watching
family feud when you got all the answers
and it's a lot easier than being under
the gun of a five second heck give her
your answer now
some crazy answers so fantastic uh i
wish everybody could have to
push a button whatever they think is
easy and somehow be morphed into doing
it and they'll see it's not
john i look forward to seeing you out
there in tahoe i always enjoy our chats
immensely thanks for the call we'll chat
soon
my pleasure thanks man i've got it right
back at you that's john smoltz
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here